quick update to a story from last week I
told you last week that or the week
before there's a major problem that we
are having with the complete and total D
monetization of virus related content on
YouTube basically YouTube has decided
anything about the virus you know the
beer bug that that virus thing YouTube
has decided it is a sensitive current
event and thus it is not brand safe so
we can produce content about the virus
we can publish content about the virus
but it's not gonna make any money
because ads won't be running on that
content now a bunch of people wrote to
me and they said David you parasite you
want to make money off of the virus
tragedy no no this isn't about profiting
from the tragedy this is about we do a
show either way we pay salaries we pay
rent we do the work why should we lose
money for covering something of public
health concern where we are trying to
disseminate information that's the
problem with Flatley d monetizing all of
the virus content and unfortunately
despite YouTube saying it might get get
better more on that in a bit it's
actually gotten worse check out our
clips published on Monday you'll see
that as of 7 p.m. Monday 4 of the prior
5 published clips were demonetized as
designated by the yellow dollar sign on
your screens our top clip compilation
was d monetized I don't even know why
maybe I mentioned the virus our story on
the stock market and oil prices was
demonetised presumably because I
mentioned also the virus is one of the
reasons the stock market imploded even
though really it was an economic story
our video about Trump saying the kovat
19 tests are beautiful was demonetized
and then our video about Trump showing
no emotion when he learned that a kid's
family was killed by a tornado that
wasn't about the virus but presumably it
was also about a sensitive current event
now people will also write to me when I
talk about this and say David I thought
you said YouTube is a private company
and it can do whatever it wants as long
as it's not illegal absolutely I'm not
questioning YouTube's legal right to do
this what I'm saying is it's absurd and
come
lately counter to encouraging creators
to responsibly cover issues of worldwide
public health importance one concern
that I'm sure is influencing this is
that around the virus there has been
crazy conspiracy stuff disinformation
you know the virus was a weapon created
in a Chinese lab you can drink liquid
silver to cure yourself I get it but
here's the thing YouTube's algorithm and
YouTube's machine learning are good
enough to know when I've said the word
virus even when it's not in the title or
the description or the tags if the
system is that good the system is good
enough to determine the difference
between conspiracy quack cures for the
virus and channels like ours
disseminating medically relevant
information of Public Health relevance
last thing on this YouTube is feeling
the pressure and they might change their
policy they tweeted a few days ago quote
creators we hear your feedback around D
monetizing videos on kovat 19 we know
you have a lot to contribute to the
global conversation so we're taking a
close look at our policies more to come
that was days ago so far no news so I
won't do a whole membership pitch here I
mean you guys know grab a membership if
you value the coverage at join
pakman.com I'm not gonna spend more time
on it it's too busy a day to do that
privacy calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy comm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit card number privacy lets you
generate virtual card numbers the
payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy com slash Pakman